After getting soaked the day before – another
night of heavy rain finally sealed the fate
of the Benito Juarez shelter in downtown Tijuana.
The 6000-plus migrants from Middle America
housed in the former sports complex did not
stand a chance against the downpour.
Only the children still manage a gentle smile.
The adults are mourning their tents floating
in ankle deep muddy water, their clothes and
other belongings drenched, ruined.
For many, a total loss.
And amid appalling sanitary conditions -Tijuana
city and Mexican federal officials saw no
other option but to shut down the shelter…
Buses arrive and open their doors – they
promise to bring these people to a “better,
safer place”
Volunteers are not hard to find.
Within hours nearly a thousand migrants are
willing to make yet another journey.
Taking with them the little they deemed worth
saving, they arrive here: El Barretal.
A former bus parking facility and concert
venue.
About 20 km from downtown Tijuana and - far
away from the border.
For some Tijuana migrants this new shelter
seems to bring some improvements:
Here the ground is concrete, not mud.
That’s better.
But most important is to have a roof over
our heads that protects us from the cold.
Others see the benefits of the new shelter
but are wary of its location.
The real reason for the police to bring us
here is that they don’t want us close to
the border.
Imagine, now we need to spend 100 pesos to
get to the border for asylum-paperwork.
We don’t have the money and it’s going
to take us all day to get there.
Now it’s even more difficult for us to get
into the United States.
Our dream is to be there.
Meanwhile back at the shelter in downtown
Tijuana the line for the buses is even longer
now.
More migrants seem to be willing to leave
for the new shelter - sooner rather than later.
A look inside the old place may reveal the
reason
“When I was a little girl”, she sings,
“I knew only the beauty of Honduras.
But as time passed by and I grew older I understood,
I should not love this land.”
The sad tune strikes a nerve with many on
this day, as they continue to harbor their
dreams of a future in a better place